I didn't have explicitly a role model
some say scientists that I wanted to be
like that person I think this is also
part of a success story because you have
to find your own way it's very important
that they do something from the bottom
of your own heart and and you find
yourself in what you do or in the work
but of course I had my scientists who
had yeah come up with fundamental and
and interesting ideas with new new ideas
I mean clearly to some extent Iceland
has always been a role model in a way of
course I'm there's no comparison with
him he was he was unique but seeing
things differently not caring about
conventions these are elements in his
attitude of course that that are there
should be role models for all of us
scientists and they are of course but I
also have great admiration for people
like Richard Fineman I read his book and
his biographies and when I was a student
and I find I find very inspiring his
attitude she explained quantum mechanics
in his own way and that was really great
because it gave you some insight and he
let that let him to do to a new way of
coming up with with with new things
quantum electrodynamics and these are
these are role models in a way but of
course I have to do my own thing and I
have to do it very much my own way